[Music]
this is joanna she thinks she has
covid19
and now she has a nostril so we can test
her
but this isn't just any nose swab it's
part of a high-tech pcr-like test called
the q-health monitoring system and you
can do it all at home no standing in
line at the testing center and then
waiting a few days to get the result see
first you insert this cartridge into
this cartridge reader then after you've
snotted up this fancy swab it gets
inserted into the cartridge
which then sends the result to your
phone
and confirmed
positive definitely did not want to be
in the same room as her but i am the
real joanna and i recently did have
kovit and i really have been testing two
new advanced at-home molecular tests
on myself
number one the q reader and q covid19
test which together start at 474
number two the detect covid test the
starter kit starts at 75
clearly these are not your 20 something
a pair box of at-home rapid antigen
tests
instead these are at-home molecular
tests that work like pcr tests so do you
really need one of these and if you do
which one do you get we're gonna get to
all of that but first you really need to
understand the difference between these
tests and those inexpensive tests
don't worry she's gonna help with it all
she's far more capable than me
okay first the at-home antigen tests
like these which have been available and
at times hard to find over the past few
months
swab the nose then place six drops here
and then stick the swab in here
here's what's happening those drops of
liquid help push the sample to the paper
and the paper itself is loaded up with
antibodies that detect an antigen or a
viral protein if detected it will be
positive if not negative these tests
which take up to 15 minutes to return
results may not detect covid19 in the
early stages of infection but they tend
to detect it when you're carrying a lot
of the virus on the other hand a
molecular test is more sensitive and can
detect covit earlier these tests use
chemicals and equipment to amplify a
sample's genetic material billions of
times to spot traces of the virus and
now you can do that all from your home
let's try the detect system to
illustrate what's happening during a
molecular test and back to swabbing
after that you insert the swab into this
test tube and stir for 15 seconds
then you open this pouch and get out
this cap and screw it on the tube the
cap has a little enzyme that helps with
the process of amplifying your sample
you shake it up real well so it all gets
mixed up together then you place it in
the detect hub
for about 55 minutes the detect app
which thankfully provides a step-by-step
guide to all this will alert you when
it's ready to be taken out
oh and we're not done then you open
another pack and squeeze the liquid from
this dropper into this reader then you
place your test tube in the chimney of
the reader then finally the sample pours
into the reader then you wait another 10
minutes and then
finally one line negative two lines
positive
the q test does pretty much the same
thing without you having to pretend
you're some sort of mad scientist
you put the q cartridge into the reader
then you put the fancy swab in your nose
and collect the sample
then you insert the swab into the
cartridge
inside it mixes with liquid and some
enzymes and then it does its thing for
about 20 minutes the reader also
connects to your phone via bluetooth
when the test is done boom your results
pop up right in the q health app so
molecular tests can detect your covet
infection earlier than antigen tests but
how much earlier
experts told me it could be anywhere
from six hours to two days and it
depends on a couple of factors including
the variant and that's pretty much how
it went for me on friday i started to
feel symptoms
a rapid antigen test said negative the
detect test positive a pcr test taken
the next morning at a lab confirmed
positive as well
by sunday the rapid antigen test said
positive
both detect and q report that they are
around 97 as accurate as a laboratory
pcr test i called up dr michael minna an
epidemiologist and covid testing expert
to ask him more about these tests and if
we can trust them he previously served
as an advisor to detect yeah you can
certainly trust trust the readout the
tools are working very well uh it's not
a new technology it's just a new
packaging
of a known technology and it's really
sort of taking what only lived in big
instruments and putting it into very
simple little boxes
so which one is better well i love the
queue it's basically a little coved
testing computer but it also costs as
much as a computer the reader is
249. and a pack of three tests is 225
you can buy it on qhealth.com the nba
mlb netflix and google are just a few
using the system eventually q wants to
sell other types of tests including flu
that you'd take and then plug into the
cartridge reader while the detect
requires more steps and takes longer to
process the result it's more affordable
which is why i bought it the starter kit
is 75 and includes the hub and one test
extra tests cost
but the company plans to bring that
price down soon you can buy it on
detect.com if they have stock the site
often says exactly what day and time
there will be more stock in but supplies
go very quickly
detect is also working on a future test
that will test for covid and flu there's
another 75 molecular test called the
lucera check it but it is a single use
test and i didn't try it while i had
kovid and it's really those higher
prices that hold back these tests from
being as useful as the antigen tests
experts told me plus you're going to
want those antigen tests as the virus
progresses and you want to get out of
quarantine
if you're trying to use a test to ask
the question
can i exit isolation and go back to work
or be around my family safely
a rapid antigen test is the test to use
that will give you that information we
just got the results we're both covered
free
molecular tests are so sensitive they
can show positive results even after the
virus is no longer alive in your body
but hey the idea of having a gadget in
your house that saves you a trip to the
doctor is the dream for now though you
need to be willing to pay way more than
those antigen tests luckily fiberglass
joanna is super duper rich
oops